Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Doan, ich bin heute der diensthabende Arzt und würde jetzt gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja Herr Doktor.
Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Anke Steigers.
Anke Steigers. Könnten Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Anke Steigers.
Um sicher zu sein, wiederhole ich.
Er ist wie Anton, er ist wie North Pole, er ist wie Kauchmann, er ist wie Emil, er ist wie Samuel, er ist wie Theodor, er ist wie Emil, er ist wie Ida, er ist wie Gustav, er ist wie Emil, er ist wie Richard und er ist wie Samuel am Ende.
Richtig?
Frau Steigers, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 66 Jahre alt.
66 Jahre alt. Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
15.05.1960.
19.06. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie Frau Steigers?
Ein Meter, 75 groß.
Wissen Sie wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ungefähr 50 Kilo Herr Doktor.
50 Kilo.
Ich bin sehr müde, ich habe sehr Müdigkeit und ich bin kaputt. Ich fühle mich sehr unangenehm. Können Sie bitte helfen?
Ja natürlich, ich bin für Sie da und kümmere mich um Ihre Beschwerden Frau Steigers. Aber zuerst soll ich wissen seit wann Sie diese Beschwerden haben.
Ja ich habe sehr starke Müdigkeit seit zwei Wochen.
Seit zwei Wochen, okay es tut mir leid dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben.
Ich bin nicht etwas vergessen und ich habe sehr übel, mir ist übel und mir ist sehr schlecht und ich komme erst ein Jahr.
Okay es tut mir leid dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben. Darf ich fragen ob es eine bestimmte Ursache gibt dass Sie sich müde fühlen und diese Beschwerden haben.
Vielleicht Schmerzen, Schlafstörungen oder irgendetwas.
Vor ein paar Wochen war ich sehr gesund aber ich hatte eine Diagnostierung bekommen und dann hat mein Hauptarzt eine Biopsie gemacht und das ist sehr bösartig.
Darf ich Sie sagen?
Ich habe ein Schweißkrebs aber ich weiß nicht.
Und dann vor vier Wochen habe ich eine Nenftnoten Entfernung bekommen und dann ja seitdem habe ich sehr angeschlagenheit und Müdigkeit sehr unangenehm Gefühl.
Alles war sehr schlecht für mich.
Um sicher zu sein fasse ich das zusammen.
Frau Steiger bei Ihnen wurde vor vier Wochen ein schwarzes Krebs.
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ja.
Und auch danach wurde bei Ihnen eine Lymphknoten Biopsie entfällt?
Vor acht Wochen eine Biopsie gemacht und dann vor vier Wochen Lymphknoten entfällt.
Achso, okay.
Okay, dann vier Wochen Lymphknoten.
Das habe ich falsch verstanden. Es tut mir leid. Ich konjugiere das.
Ich habe eine Chemo alle zwei Wochen bekommen und das war vor zwei Wochen.
Vor zwei Wochen.
Haben Sie die Chemotherapie-Chema dabei?
Nein.
Okay. Wie heißt Ihr Onkolog?
Frau Müller.
Frau Müller, okay.
Ich kann Ihnen eine Handynummer geben.
Ja natürlich. Ich kann erreichen. Nach dem Gespräch werde ich eine Verbindung mit ihr binden. Setzen, kein Problem.
Okay. Sie leiden unter Müdigkeit und Übelkeit. Gibt es noch weitere Beschwerden wie Schmerzen?
Wie gesagt, ich fühle mich nicht gut. Ich habe einige Nasenbluten. Viermal. Und ungefähr dauert es 15 Minuten.
15 Minuten dauert es.
Verstehe nicht. Ist das gefühlt, die Doktornasenbluten?
Das kann höchstwahrscheinlich eine Nebenwirkung der Chemotherapie sein. Aber wir werden das abklären. Machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Aber das kann eine Nebenwirkung der Chemotherapie sein.
Okay. Sie leiden keine Schmerzen. Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Okay, okay. Das wollte ich wissen.
Schmerzen, Schluckbeschwerden, wenn ich etwas wüsste. Ich habe einige sehr starke Schmerzen im linken Leistenbereich.
Leisten? Ist das der Biopsidbereich?
Seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Seit vier Wochen.
Ich habe eine Operation dabei.
Wie bitte? Ich konnte nicht akustisch gut verstehen.
Eine Operation dabei. Lymphknotenentfernung.
Sie haben aber schon erwähnt, vor wie vielen Wochen eine Lymphknotenbiopsie bei Ihnen durchgeführt?
Ja, ja. Am gleichen Bereich hatte ich eine Schmerzen.
Okay. Darf ich wissen oder fragen, wo befindet sich Ihre Hautkrebs?
Im welchem Körperteil?
Im linken Bein.
Linken Bein.
Der Hautarzt hat eine Biopsie gemacht.
Ja, das habe ich verstanden.
Ganz gleich Oberschenkel.
Oberschenkel, okay. Wichtig zu wissen, das habe ich auch notiert.
Frau Steigers, wo genau sind die Schmerzen im linken oder rechten Leistungsbereich?
Im linken.
Okay. Strahlen Sie die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, meine Schmerzen sind im linken Bein.
Okay. Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Nach der Operation hatte ich plötzlich Schmerzen.
Das ist schlimmer geworden.
Und manchmal in der Rücken ausstrahlen.
Auch in der Rücken ausstrahlen? Okay.
In der Rücken und im linken Bein.
Ich vermute, dass die Schmerzen immer da sind.
Ja, immer da.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
Wobei 0 keine Schmerzen und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen bedeutet.
6 bis 10.
Okay. Könnten Sie das aushalten oder brauchen Sie ein Medikament Schmerzmittel?
Ja, ich kann das aushalten. Das sind nicht neue Schmerzen.
Aber Herr Doktor, wenn ich ein bisschen Bewegung zum Beispiel oder die linkseitige legen, ist das schlimmer geworden.
Aber ich habe gehört, dass ich Ibu 600 mg einnehme.
Ist es besser geworden?
Besser. Gut. Ich habe das auch notiert.
Wie war das Skala nach einer Einnahme von Ibu?
Was meinen Sie?
Wie stark ist die Stärke Ihrer Schmerzen nach einer Einnahme von Ibu?
1 bis 2.
Okay, gut. Ich denke, dass Ibu dabei Ihnen helfen.
Das ist es.
Okay, gut. Könnten Sie mir die Schmerzen genau beschreiben, Frau Steigers?
Stechend, brennend oder?
Wie gesagt, ein bisschen krampfartig und dumpf.
Krampfartig und dumpf. Okay, wichtig zu wissen.
Frau Steigers, das habe ich notiert.
Gibt es noch andere Beschwerden, die gleichzeitig auftreten?
Zum Beispiel leiden Sie auch unter Atemnot oder Blutung im Kölb, außer Nasen, blaue Flecken?
Ich habe ein bisschen Luftnot und ich habe gemerkt, dass ich eine geschwollene linke Beine hatte.
Oh, ich will das. Das ist wichtig zu wissen.
Ein bisschen gerottet, ja.
Ich will eine linke Beine.
Seit wann leiden Sie unter Düsbne?
Düsbne? Was meinen Sie?
Entschuldigung, Luftnot?
Luftnot, ach so. Ich habe ein bisschen Luftnot.
Manchmal verwechsel ich die Wörter, Fachbegriff oder Alltagssprache.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, Herr Doppter.
Seit wann?
Seit ungefähr vier Wochen.
Okay. Und wann haben Sie dieses geschwollene Bein bemerkt?
Ungefähr vier Wochen nach der Operation habe ich es bemerkt.
Direkt nach der Operation hatten Sie dieses geschwollene Bein?
Seit vier Wochen eine gerottete und geschwollene.
Auch gerottete, nicht geschwollene, auch gerottete. Das ist wichtig zu wissen.
Ja, und dann hatte ich eine geschwollene Gerote dabei.
Okay. Ja, und das ist eine...
Haben Sie Fieber gleichzeitig oder Störfrost?
Nachtschweiß? Kalten Schweiß? Okay.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen, Frau Steigers?
Nein.
Bezüglich Ihrer Luftnot würde ich gerne wissen.
Nein, nur Luftnot.
Okay. Und Sie leiden unter Übelkeit. Müssen Sie sich auch übergeben?
Nein, nur über die Übelkeit.
Seit wann?
Ich konnte nicht etwas essen.
Ja, auch in der Petenz. Ich vermute, dass Sie auch...
Ich habe ungefähr 5 Kilo innerhalb von zwei Wochen abgenommen.
Ja, es tut mir leid, dass Sie das erleben mussten.
Aber Sie hatten ein bisschen viel Gewichtverlust.
Okay. Aber wie gesagt, machen Sie es keine Sorge.
Wir werden alle notwendigen Untersuchungen für Sie hier durchführen.
Okay. Und ich vermute, dass Sie nicht gut schlafen können. Bin ich korrekt oder?
Ja, ich habe sehr starke Schmerzen und ich konnte nicht mehr gut schlafen.
Wegen Schmerzen. Okay.
Manchmal habe ich haloperidol, halodol, ungefähr 5 Tropfen bei Bedarf, wenn ich nicht gut schlafe.
Nehmen Sie haloperidol gegen Schlafstörungen oder Gegenübelkeit?
Bei Bedarf, ja. Bei Bedarf.
Bei Bedarf, okay.
Frau Steyrger, Sie sind 66 Jahre alt. Ich vermute, dass Sie in Wechseljahren sind. Seit wann sind Sie in Wechseljahren?
Seit 15 Jahren.
15 Jahren. Okay. Besuchen Sie Ihre Frau regelmäßig?
Ja, ich besuche sie regelmäßig. Alles ist in Ordnung.
Okay, gut. Gibt es in Ihren...
... Probleme.
Wie bitte?
Ich habe keine gynäkologischen Probleme.
Okay, gut zu wissen. Gibt es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel chronische Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit, erhöhte Blutverdwerte?
Ich habe keine anderen Erkrankungen.
Ja, gut zu wissen. Und außer dieser Biopsie oder Entfernung, Lymphknotenentfernung, hatten Sie andere Operationen?
Ja, ich hatte einen Unfall vor zehn Jahren und ich habe eine Unterarmfraktur gebrochen und ich habe eine Operation in der linken Unterarm.
Linken Unterarm. Okay.
Alles war in Ordnung.
Okay. Ja, alles war in Ordnung. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente außer Ibuprofen 600 mg und Haloperidol-Tropfen ein?
Haloperidol-Tropfen bei Bedarf nehme ich ein, aber Ibuprofen seit vier Wochen 600 mg, viermal täglich.
Viermal täglich. Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Ihrem Magen?
Nein.
Okay, gut zu wissen.
Ich habe Schluckbeschwerden.
Ja, das habe ich notiert.
Ja.
Okay. Ja, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung kümmere ich mich um auch diese Beschwerden und ich untersuche diese Beschwerde auch.
Und sind Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt, Frau Steigers?
Keine Allergien.
Keine Allergien und keine Unverträglichkeiten. Kann ich das so notieren?
Ja, stimmt.
Okay. Darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben, Frau Steigers?
Ich habe nie geraucht.
Ja, super. Ich gratuliere Ihnen. Und ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie trinken?
Ja, ergellentlich am Wochenende ein bis zwei Gläser Wein. Aber nur ergellentlich.
Ein bis zwei Gläser Wein am Wochenende. Okay.
Also routinemäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben, Frau Steigers.
Ich habe keinen Kontakt mit Drogen. Keinen Kontakt.
Gut, gut zu wissen. Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich habe ein vollständiges Kind.
Jetzt würde ich noch einige Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen. Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Mein Vater ist an Bruch-Hierkast noch verstorben. Er war 65 Jahre alt. Aber meine Mutter ...
Es tut mir leid für Ihren Verlust, Frau Steigers.
Was ist mit Ihrer Mutter?
Meine Mutter lebt noch und sie ist 67 Jahre alt. Aber sie hat einen Schlaganfall.
Wie bitte? 67 oder?
Nein, 87. Entschuldigung.
Okay.
Ich bin nicht gut, Erdenin. Entschuldigung. Ich bin sehr mutter, Herr Doktor.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Meine Mutter hat einen Schlaganfall. Warum hat sie einen einseitigen oder linksseitigen Schlaganfall, Herr Doktor?
Frau Steigers, ein Schlaganfall ist eine Durchblutungsstörung im Gehirn.
Dabei bekommt ein Teil des Gehirns nicht Sauerstoff. Vielleicht manchmal linksseitig oder rechtsseitig.
Es hängt davon ab, welches Gehirnbereich betroffen ist.
Danke schön, Herr Doktor. Herr Doktor, was habe ich?
Entschuldigung. Ich bitte um ein bisschen Geduld. Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen zu Ihrem Familienstand und sozialen Anamnesen.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Frau Steigers?
Ja, verheiratet und ich habe eine gesunde Tochter.
Gut, so ist es.
Ich bin nicht gearbeitet, aber früher war ich ein Anwohner im Meldamt.
Ein Anwohner im Meldamt, okay.
Ich habe Arbeitsunfähigkeit.
Okay, das habe ich notiert.
Frau Steigers, ich danke nochmals Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und Ihre Geduld. Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Laut Ihren Beschwerden habe ich einen Verdacht auch neben Wirkungen der Chemotherapie.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung. Deshalb müssen wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen, um das zu bestätigen.
Zunächst werde ich mich mit Ihrem Onkologen in Verbindung setzen.
Danach werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, einen EKG schreiben, um mögliche Herzursachen auszuschließen und Ihnen anschließend Blut für das Labo abnehmen.
Und ich werde danach einen Ultraschall Ihrer Leiste und Ihrem Bein durchführen. Okay?
Herr Doktor, die Ärzte haben schon gesagt, dass ich keine Sorgen machen werde.
Aber mein Vater ist an Bronchiakarsenom gestorben.
Ich konnte nicht sehr gut denken und alle Ärzte sagen genaue Sätze.
Zum Beispiel sagen sie, sie machen keine Sorge, aber wenn ich sterbe, ist das gefährlich für mich.
Frau Steigers, ich kann Ihre Sorge, Ihre Angst sehr gut und ganz gut verstehen.
Alle sind ganz nachvollziehbar. Ich meine alle Sorge, Gedanken und auch Angst.
Aber es ist sehr wichtig, immer Hoffnung zu sein.
Wir werden alle notwendigen Untersuchungen für Sie machen. Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Aber ich werde diese Untersuchungen durchführen, bevor ich Ihnen etwas Genaues sage.
Das ist sehr wichtig, immer hoffnungsvoll zu sein.
Und hoffnungsvoll zu bleiben.
Bei solchen schwierigen Situationen wird es immer folgen.
Ich empfehle Ihnen auch so zu sein.
Sobald Ihre Ergebnisse vorliegen, bespreche ich alles mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erkläre Ihnen Schritt für Schritt, wie es weitergeht.
Ich bitte nochmals um Ihre Geduld.
Sie sollten hier bleiben und Sie sollten auf mich warten. Ich komme gleich.
Danke schön.
Herr Kavlar, möchtest du einen Anruf machen?
Ja, Dr. Doan am Apparat.
Guten Tag, ich bin Frau Müller.
Bitte Frau Müller.
Herr Lorenz mit SET am Ende.
Die Thrombocyt-Werte sind 15.200.
15.200?
Das ist zu wenig.
Ja, pro Mikroliter. Könnten Sie bitte diese Werte Ihrem Oberarzt zügig weiterleiten?
Ich mache sofort das. Ich mache gerne sofort.
Danke. Tschüss.
Guten Tag.
Guten Tag, mein Oberarzt.
Können Sie sich kurz vorstellen?
Ja, ich bin Teten Doan. Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Ich bin 41 Jahre alt und lebe seit mehr als 2,5 Jahren in Deutschland.
Ich habe Deutsch gelernt und jetzt bin ich für diese Prüfung hier.
Warum sind Sie nach Deutschland gekommen?
Bis ich nach Deutschland gekommen bin, habe ich in der Türkei als Arzt 12 Jahre gearbeitet.
Mein Medizinstudium habe ich 2009 an der Universität Istanbul Cera Pasar abgeschlossen.
Danach habe ich als Assistenarzt in der Pathologieabteilung 2 Jahre lang und in der Medizin 4 Jahre lang gearbeitet.
Aber im Jahr 2017 musste ich meine Stelle an der Universität verlassen.
Aus politischen Gründen.
Bis 2023 habe ich als Allgemeinarzt in der Notaufnahme gearbeitet.
Weil ich die Lebensbedingungen in der Türkei als unsicher und schwierig empfinde, habe ich mich entschieden, nach Deutschland zu kommen.
Hauptsache war für meine Entscheidung die politische Gründe.
Ok, ich kann verstehen. Sie haben viel Erfahrung in der Türkei.
Was ist Ihr Ziel in Deutschland?
Mein Ziel in Deutschland ist es, meine bisherigen Kenntnisse zu ergänzen.
Die notwendigen Fortbildungen oder Weiterbildungen zu absolvieren, dann als Hauser zu arbeiten.
Ich möchte in Deutschland als Hausarzt arbeiten.
Aber inzwischen habe ich Fortbildungen gemacht, um meine Deutschkenntnisse zu verbessern.
Natürlich um mein Deutschgesundheitssystem zu wissen und um meine Kenntnisse zu erfrischen und zu vertiefen.
Was haben Sie noch heute für uns?
Frau Obersting, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Aber bevor ich meinen Patienten vorstelle, möchte ich Ihnen etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Oder muss ich etwas wichtiges mitteilen?
Ich habe einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Ich soll Ihnen sagen, dass Herr Lorenz einen Thrombocytin von 15.200 pro Mikroliter hat.
Das ist sehr niedrig und lebensbedrohlich im Rahmen der spontanen Blutungen.
Ich möchte Ihnen sofort darüber informieren.
Was bedeutet das?
Ja, wie gesagt, eine Thrombocytopenie kann unter anderem, das ist lebensbedrohlich wegen der Spontanblutungen, wegen der Wahrscheinlichkeit der Spontanblutungen.
Sie haben schon diese gefährliche Situation erklärt.
Aber früher sagten Sie nicht, dass es eine Thrombocytopenie ist.
Entschuldigung, ja. Natürlich bezeichnet man das als Thrombocytopenie.
Weil die Thrombocytin-Zeit nicht im Nonbereich, sondern sogar sehr niedrig ist.
Okay. Andere Patienten?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Sie ist Frau Anke Steigers.
Sie ist 66 Jahre alt, geboren am 15.05.1960.
Sie ist 1,75 Meter groß und 50 Kilo schwer oder wiegt 50 Kilo.
Sie kam heute zu uns wegen seit zwei Wochen bestehender Müdigkeit und auch seit vier Wochen bestehender Schmerzen.
Schmerzen in dem linken ungenalen Bereich.
Laut Aussage der Patientin sind die Schmerzen nach der Lymphadenektomie plötzlich aufgetreten.
Sie berichtet, die Patientin berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in das linke Bein und auch in den Rücken ausstreilen.
Nach Angaben der Patientin sind die Schmerzen krampfartig.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 von 10 auf der NRS.
Es gibt eine Linderung nach Einnahme von Ibuprofen 600 mg.
Falls Einnahme von Ibuprofen liegt die Schmerzintensität bei 1 von 10 auf der NRS.
Die Schmerzen verschlimmen sich bei linkseitigem Hinlegen.
Außerdem erwähnt sie, dass vor sechs Wochen ein malignes Melanom diagnostiziert wurde.
Der Patient ist nicht genau beschrieben, aber im linken Oberschenkel.
Die Frage nach der Flasche der Oberschenkel wurde nicht gestellt.
Ich werde bei der körperlichen Untersuchung direkt beobachten.
Der Patient erwähnt, dass vor zwei Wochen eine Chemotherapie eingeführt wurde.
Seit der ersten Chemotherapie leidet der Patient unter Übelkeit, Schluckbeschwerden und Inapetens.
Was ist das Begriff?
Das ist der Verdacht auf Oralulzere wegen der Mykositischen Schleimhautentzündung.
Ich frage, was ist das Fachbegriff?
Das ist die Diagnose der Schleimhautentzündung.
Die Schleimhautentzündung leidet seit zwei Wochen unter Epistaxis.
Die Schleimhautentzündung leidet seit ein paar Wochen unter Epistaxis.
Durchschnittlich dauert sie 15 Minuten.
Begleitend zu dieser Beschwerden und Vegetative anamnestisch ergaben sich schmerzbedingte Dysomnie und ein Gewichtsverlust von 5 Kilo in zwei Wochen.
Sie hatte natürlich Inapetens und hatte eine sehr große Angst.
Die Gynäkologie anamnese war unaufällig.
Und außer dieser Krankheit leidet sie an keinen Krankheiten.
Und an Vorerkrankungen außer Lymphknotämie eine Osteosynthese vor zehn Jahren bekannt.
Sie haben gesagt Vorerkrankungen.
An Vorerkrankungen ist eine Osteosynthese wegen einem Unfall bekannt.
Sie nimmt Haloperidol gegen Dysomnie und Ibuprofen 600 mg täglich viermal gegen Schmerzen ein.
Hat sie Fieber?
Diese Frage wurde verneint.
Ist die Wundestelle gerötet oder überwarmt oder geschwollen?
Diese Frage wurde nicht gestellt.
Sie haben gestellt.
Gerötet oder überwarmt.
Nein, das war eine wichtige Frage.
Sie hat geschwollene Beine.
Sie berichtete eine geschwollene, gerötete Beine.
Aber im Leistungsbereich musste ich diese Frage stellen.
Aber ich habe vergessen.
Ich werde bei der körperlichen Untersuchung direkt beobachten, ob die Wunde geschwollen, gerötet oder überwarmt ist.
Die Allergienamnese war unauffällig.
Bei der Nuxenamnese berichtete sie über den Konsum.
Ein bis zwei Gläser Wein pro Woche.
Die Drogen- und Nikotinkonsum wurden verneint.
Die Familienamnese ergab einen Bronzschallkarzinom beim Vater und einen Apoplex bei der Mutter.
Sozial-amnestisch ist sie verheiratet, hat eine gesunde Tochter.
Sie ist in der Regel beim Einwohnermeldamt.
Aber zu seit ist sie arbeitsunfähig.
Was ist Ihre Verdacht?
Nach den anamnestischen Angaben habe ich eine…
Ich möchte darüber fragen.
Deswegen habe ich meine Verdachtdiagnose verändert bei diesem Fall.
Ich möchte sagen, in diesem Fall eine chemotherapieinduzierte Pancitopenie.
Geht es? Vielleicht später sprechen wir darüber.
Das passt.
Nach den anamnestischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht, eine chemotherapieinduzierte Pancitopenie.
Dafür sprechen Mühe, Epistaxis, Dysphagie, Inapetens, Gewichtsverlust von 5,2 Kilo, Übelkeit,
eine wundheilige Störung und eine TvT in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich natürlich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Aber bevor muss ich mit Ihren Onkologen eine Verbindung setzen, um mehr zu erfahren.
Danach werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Dann nehme ich Blut ab.
Dann werde ich Blut für das Leben abnehmen und eine EKG schreiben.
Sind Sie eine EKG schreiben?
Sie hat Düspne und wegen meiner Verdachtdiagnose leidet sie unter Anämie.
Deswegen sollte eine EKG durchgeführt werden um eine kardiale Ursache auszuschließen.
Vielleicht tatsächlich.
Chemotherapie kann auch viele Dinge machen.
Sie haben recht.
Chemotherapie kann auch natürlich kardiotoxisch sein.
Deswegen ist es wichtig bei diesen Patienten eine EKG zu schreiben.
Weil die Patientin unter geschwollenem und geröteten Bein leidet,
soll ich eine Duplex Sonographie durchführen um eine mögliche TvT auszuschließen.
Gleichzeitig hat die Patientin auch Düspne und eine geschwollene, gerötete und überwärmte Bein.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Natürlich kann man den Wundenbereich mit Ultraschall...
Den Wundenbereich werde ich sonografisch untersuchen.
Wird das eine Kultur der Wundenstellen sein?
Ja. Ich habe schon gesagt, dass Sie Fragen nach Wunden nicht gestellt haben.
Ich habe vor, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung danach zu fragen.
Wenn ich die Wunde oder am Wunde eine Heilungsstörung finde oder ein Zündungszeichen beobachte,
würde ich natürlich die Kultur abnehmen und einen Ultraschall durchführen.
Im Labor würde ich Blutbild-, Entzündungsparameter, einschließlich Procalcitonin und Elektrolyte, Nieren- und Leberwerte, auch Gerinnungsparameter, unter anderem die Dedima,
der Dedima ist wichtig beim Verdacht auf Lungenembolie oder TvT und Herzmuskeln, Enzyme und Blutzucker kontrollieren lassen.
Ich habe alle die notwendigen erste schrittliche Untersuchungen genannt.
Ich werde natürlich ein physio- und ein Onkologisches Konzil anfordern, weil der Patient unter großer Todangst leidet.
Wie können Sie die Patienten behandeln?
Sollte sich die Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen und unkeh isolieren, um die Patienten zu schützen.
Ich würde eine Infusiontherapie, Flüssigkeitzufuhr und Elektrolytsubstitution und Nahrungsstoffzufuhr auch verordnen.
Ich werde auch eine symptomatische Behandlung mit Wundversorgung, Analgetikum, Antiemetikum verordnen.
Gegebenenfalls wird eine Antibiotik verordnet, falls es eine wundheilige oder entzündliche Wunde beobachtet wird.
Warum sollte die Patientin isoliert werden?
Sollte sich die Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, muss man diese Patienten unkeh isolieren, weil sie höchstwahrscheinlich Lokopenie hat.
Das ist auch wichtig, weil Chemotherapie eine Pancitopenie in einschließlich Lokopenie verursachen kann.
Deswegen werde ich diese Patienten isolieren.
Was kann bei dieser Situation entstehen?
Bei dieser Situation ist die Pancitopenie verbrillt.
Obwohl die Frage nach Fieber verneint wurde,
Warum kann die Patientin keine Fieber haben?
Sie nimmt täglich viermal Ibuprofen als Schmerzmittel, das ist auch Antipiratikum.
Ein einfaches Virus oder ein Mikroorganismus kann die Patientin sterben.
Deswegen soll ich diese Patientin unkeh isolieren.
Sehr gut gemacht.
Ich habe keine anderen Fragen.
Ich habe eine weitere Frage.
Was ist mit der Reaktion?
Ich verstehe Ihre Angst ganz gut.
Heute gibt es viele Therapiemöglichkeiten, um die Lebensqualität zu verbessern und die Lebensverlängerung zu erreichen.
Ich habe diese Anzeige schon mal genannt, aber ich habe keine Erfahrung.
Ich habe auch noch keine Erfahrung.
Aber diese Patientin, unsere Seele ist durch diese Situation, diese Patientin zu schützen.
Deswegen sollen wir uns nicht isolieren.
So etwas. Du kannst es einfach so beschreiben.
Vielen Dank.
Ich glaube, es gibt keine Anzeige, die sich über diese Situation befassen wollen.
Okay, dann.
Ich habe nichts mehr zu sagen.
Wir haben schon über die Fragen gesprochen.
Herr Sümeyra, wir haben es schon gesagt, dass wir uns nicht mehr mit der Pans-Topeni-Diagnose umsetzen.
Was ist Ihr Meinung auf die Differenzial-Diagnose?
Ich habe die Differenzial-Diagnose, wie der Herr Chetin sagte, gemacht.
Ich habe die Differenzial-Diagnose gemacht.
Okay, ich habe auch schon mal in den Berichten gesagt, dass ich die Pulsatophonikation in der Klinik nicht so gut erinnere.
Das ist die Anzeige, die Pans-Topeni-Diagnose.
Wir haben die Differenzial-Diagnose gemacht, um die Anzeige zu beweisen.
Aber es gibt zwei Gründe, die ich hier nennen.
Ich denke, dass es mit der Pans-Topeni-Diagnose etwas mit der Pans-Topeni-Diagnose zu tun hat.
Aber es kann auch mit der Pans-Topeni-Diagnose etwas mit der Pans-Topeni-Diagnose zu tun haben.
Okay, danke.
Vielen Dank.